[Music]
you know if you're still a fan of any
hollywood film franchise now would be a
good time to abandon ship i mean the
problem with hollywood franchises is
first of all almost all of them are
lifeless and redundant as they exist
only to perpetuate and profit off of the
brand of course all movies are supposed
to make money but the difference is that
franchises like marvel and star wars and
others
have no purpose beyond that the next
installment in the series doesn't come
into being because someone really wants
to tell the story
and convinces a studio to sign on
rather the next installment is the
result of people sitting around in a
room and saying you know we need to ring
another 90 minutes out of this anyone
got any ideas as far as i'm concerned
that's reason enough to stop watching
these glorified cash grabs
the other is that every single one of
them
has gone or will go
woke
in fact at this point someone somewhat
incredibly
wokification comes before profitability
on a studio's list of concerns
the films exist to keep the brand
relevant and make money off of them yes
that's the motivation which spurs them
into being that's why they're conceived
but the first priority upon conception
is to make sure that the script is
orthodox and in keeping with the
prevailing doctrines of the day
they'll actually sacrifice some of the
profits in order to do this
so in summary before you sit down to
watch any new installment in any
hollywood franchise you know from the
start that it will be cynical left-wing
agit prop which was made only to
increase the studios profits and brand
awareness and to propagate deranged
leftist values
any entertainment value outside of all
that will be an accidental byproduct
and of course if you wish to be
entertained you must first assume the
mentality of a person with room
temperature iq and no standards or
self-respect
and this mental maneuver proves to be
pretty easy for some people probably
because they don't have to assume that
mentality so much as they already have
it going in but these are all just
things to keep in mind as the new james
bond movie is set to release next week i
have no specific information confirming
this but i can already guarantee
that it will be the wokest james bond
film in the history of the franchise it
couldn't exist in the year 2021 if it
weren't
there have been some indications though
like the actress who plays the new bond
girl
announced that her character will be the
most badass bond girl in history
of course nobody watches james bond
hoping to see a badass bond girl they
want james bond to be badass the bond
girl is supposed to be pretty that's
really her only job at least it was her
only job back before wokeness became the
overriding priority indeed the push now
is to turn the entire bond franchise
into a girl power vehicle
lately lately the cries have been
deafening from the media anyway not so
much from the movie going public
for a female james bond
with daniel craig leaving the role after
this next film
it seems inevitable that the character
will finally undergo this gender
transition and many outlets have been
publishing articles listing helpful
suggestions for which actress might be
suitable to fill james bond's shoes
vogue for example says that um kate
blanchette
victoria victoria beckham or emily blunt
might be perfect for the role
yes because when i think of someone who
might be credibly portrayed as a
kick-ass action hero who can beat up a
room full of bad guys and then drive
away in their fancy sports car and make
it to the villain's lair just in time to
vanquish him and foil his dastardly plot
when i think about that
my mind immediately turns to
kate blanchette
but this is the problem with female
action heroes in general
for all i know
daniel craig and keanu reeves and the
rock and even liam neeson
might be big softies who punch like
girls in real life but they have at
least a screen presence and an aura that
makes them seem like the kinds of guys
you wouldn't want to mess with
does any female actress really have that
quality
charlie starin played an elite spy and
assassin in the movie atomic blonde a
few years ago
would anyone actually be worried if
charlize theron was mad at them in real
life
is anyone going to run away and say i
hope charles theron doesn't beat me up
does charlize theron have any natural
intimidation factor
does gal gadot does brie larson
see this is the problem
most female action
movies come with this natural silliness
factor
and there's a certain silliness to all
action films but the ones that reeves
and nieces and craig star and tend to
also reach sometimes successfully
sometimes not for a certain dark and
gritty and serious tone
but you can't often do that with the
female lead films they all have to be
cartoons in the end because when it
comes down to it you're still watching a
hot 100 pounds supermodel do her best
jason statham impression and it's just
kind of funny
daniel craig was asked this question
about whether there should be a female
james bond and he said no
but he made sure to qualify his answer
by saying that there ought to be new
franchises just as good as james bond
and similar to james bond built around
female action stars he argues that women
deserve their own heroes rather than
constantly appropriating already
existing male heroes
and he's on the right track with that
answer but he's missing something
and even if he's not missing this he
would never say it out loud anyway
and it's this
yes there should be films about female
heroes
yes they should have their own films
rather than simply taking male
characters and giving them sex
reassignments
but these women heroes
should also be heroic
in womanly ways
okay rather than having female
protagonists who are heroically
masculine
why not female protagonists who are
heroically feminine
not all heroism involves beating people
up and driving cars really fast in fact
in real life the vast majority of heroic
acts
don't include any of that unfortunately
i have known many heroic women in my
life
and none of them so far as i know
have ever thrown a punch at all which is
good because they probably break their
wrists if they did
physical courage is but one type
there's also moral courage
emotional courage
intellectual courage and all of these
types of courage come wrapped up in what
i would call maternal courage
a good mother like my wife for example
shows courage every day even though she
may go her whole life and never have to
drop kick any assassin or defuse any
bomb
now i realize that it's harder to make a
compelling film
that showcases the quieter less physical
forms of courage
but these are the very kinds of courage
that society looks to women to exhibit
and provide
which means that if we really want women
represented on screen as female heroes
and not merely as female heroes
pretending to be male heroes
then it might be time to start investing
in scripts and stories
that have a little more depth
and a little more nuance
and that's why before she even exists
i have to today cancel
the female james bond or jane bond or
whatever we're gonna call it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated